[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
without further ado where have we been
these past several weeks will recall
that over the past couple of weeks we've
been introducing web programming and
most recently did we try to tie together
a lot of the topics from the past few
weeks HTML and CSS and JavaScript and
then Python and then another framework
another piece of software called flash
that just made it easier and more
possible to build web based applications
and the simplest example of that last
week recall looked a little something
like this
in this past week with the problems on
similarities and survey have you been
building your own web based applications
but they haven't quite had all of the
pieces that you might want to assemble
into a web-based app and so today we'll
fill in those final blanks but recall
that we've been trying to frame these
applications not as one-off or just
tools that you built but as part of a
common paradigm or a methodology and
indeed when you're learning computer
science and software engineering you
start to notice patterns in the software
and the code that you're writing and
humans tend to adopt these patterns
because they save you time and then
everyone can kind of speak the same
language so to speak so MVC was the
acronym we introduced last week
model-view-controller and that just
speaks to this paradigm whereby you
organize certain type of code in one
file certain types of other code in
another file so your Python code goes in
application pi your HTML goes in your
HTML files your CSS and your CSS files
and so forth but what we didn't have
last week was this thing here really
model generally refers to your data and
while survey your most recent problem
did have data a CSV file that's arguably
a model CSV is not terribly expressive
you can pretty much just write rows text
file
rows to a text file not unlike a
spreadsheet but you can't really query
yet you can't easily insert or delete
you pretty much would have to
reconstruct the whole file and indeed
that's exactly what I did back in the
day the very first web-based application
I wrote back in sophomore or junior year
was the freshman intramural website and
all I had available to me both
technologically and conceptually were
CSV files I had no idea what databases
were didn't realize how much easier they
could make my life so I stored all of
the data behind these links here just in
very simple text files but today will
give you so much more power
if you're coming into the class with an
interest in applying CS to other fields
and medicine or the arts or any world in
which there's data particularly in stem
and data science and the like realize
that sequel has really become this this
incredibly powerful language with which
to solve problem in those and so many
domains and ultimately what you build
this coming week your very last cs50
problem set you have now peaked just
about um will be cs50 finance a
web-based application via which you can
buy or or buy and sell stocks and so
what you're going to do this coming week
is write code that implements a web
application that resembles this whereby
your users and yourself will be able to
register for an account log into that
account you'll be given for free thanks
to us 10,000 virtual dollars and then
you can go ahead and buy and sell stocks
via their symbol using this application
so for instance if I go ahead and
register myself here let's say username
Mahlon password one two three four five
shouldn't have said that go ahead and
register here you'll see that by default
I get this free ten thousand dollars in
virtual cash you know what I'm gonna go
ahead and buy myself a share of maybe
Netflix whose symbol is NFLX
I'm gonna go ahead and try to buy one
share voila and now you'll see that not
only do I have less cash left about nine
thousand six hundred dollars I now own a
share of stock and if we reload this
throughout the lecture frankly the price
might go a little up or a little down
because this web application you'll
build will also talk to an API an
application programming interface so
some third-party website that provides
you with stock data so you ask it for
the current price of a stock it gives
you an answer in JSON format if you
recall our short discussion of that and
you'll integrate it ultimately into this
interface so this will be the
culmination of so many of the ideas in
the building boxwood which you've
experimented but we need a few final
pieces today so first and foremost when
I registered for this site I created an
account and indeed I can go ahead and
log out now and if I go ahead and log
back in if no one's stolen my password
yet I can see my account and only my
account but we haven't yet seen any
mechanism in code whereby you can
implement this notion of logging in
right what is the underlying logic via
which a website no
that you are logged in or you're not
logged in right clearly when I went to
this website just a moment ago it
prompted me to log in because I was not
because I had logged out but how did it
know that and now that I am logged in
how does it know that I can click on
quote to get just the stock quote or by
just a buy a stock or sell why does it
not prompt to me every time I click a
link to log back in with my username or
password what do you think cookies
little files that get saved by websites
on your computer now odds are most
everyone here has probably heard in some
form cookies bad maybe bad privacy in
beta and guess ok so true but most of
the web would not work without them so
someone else
what do you understand a cookie to be
what is a cookie yeah it saves your
information so I'm sorry you don't Huff
so you don't have to put it in every
time so in simplest form it's exactly a
combination of those answers whereby
when I log into a web site you could
imagine that website just remembering my
username and my password by just saving
them in a little file on my Mac or PC so
that the next time I visit a webpage it
just automatically sends them for me so
that the human doesn't have to type them
again and again
now let's find fault with that feels
like that would work but what's the
downside of that naive implementation
what do you think instinctively
the data is just out there right you
know I have people in you know in the
office or at home or in a you know
library that I might not want to just be
able to walk up to that computer and
just see this little text file planted
on my computer because then they could
log in to my account by just digging
around so feels a little invasive indeed
that's one of the threats of cookies so
it turns out cookies or web sites tend
not to do that at least if they're
implemented well they instead just plant
a really big random number on your hard
drive or in your computer's RAM or
memory so one two three four five six
Epting like some really big number maybe
with letters and numbers maybe even some
punctuation that uniquely identifies me
and thereafter anytime I click a link on
that same website after logging in my
browser thanks to HTTP the language that
browsers and servers speak that we just
a few weeks back just magically sends
that same big random number to the
server again and again and so long as
the server remembers that that big
random number corresponds to username
Mahlon it can figure out whose account
to show and why is it a big random
number why is it not just my password or
my user name why am i proposing that it
be a big random number exactly in
computer science randomness this is
incredibly powerful ingredient if you
pick a big enough word or a big enough
string or sentence the probability that
some random adversary or bad person on
the Internet is gonna be able to guess
or try to guess that value it's just so
low it's just not realistically ever
gonna happen in your lifetime
statistically and so randomness gives us
that capability and so you can think
about this metaphorically in the real
world is being like a hand stamp if
you've ever gone to like an amusement
park or a bar or Club where you have to
show your ID or you have to pay for a
ticket on the way in sometimes they'll
stamp you with either visible or
invisible ink and that's largely for
efficiency so that they're after when
you're in the amusement park you can
kind of come and go and you don't have
to repay or reprocess if you're in the
bar or the club you don't have to keep
showing your ID they can check once and
then more efficiently let you come and
go as you please because you're just
presenting your hand or this virtual
hand stamp to the bouncer or to the
gatekeeper at those places so cookies
are exactly like that unbeknownst to us
all this time any time you visit a
website into which you've logged in your
browser is secretly but usefully
presenting a hand stamp to that server
to remind it who you are or rather not
really who you are but of that big
random number so that if the server
remembers who that number belongs to it
can figure out whose account to then
show so put more concretely if I
actually pull up some of the HTTP
examples that we looked at in the past
let's consider this in context so almost
everyone here is probably used Gmail at
some point and you log in generally by a
page like this so it might be infrequent
because you're not often prompted to log
into Gmail because of surprise surprise
cookies from Google being on your
computer but let's see where those come
from so when you request Google or gmail
com you might send in a virtual envelope
so to speak from your Mac or PC to the
server
message like this families who've not
seen this before this is what your
browser is actually sending to a server
in order to request a home page of Gmail
com now I'm gonna simplify this a little
bit because there's a bunch of redirects
HTTP 302s and 301 s involved that aren't
that interesting today so let's just
assume that Gmail responds immediately
typically Gmail would respond with this
saying 200 okay here's the login page
and here's a web page in text flash HTML
format but once you've logged in what
Gmail actually does is it also sends
this recall that we called these things
HD HTTP headers key value pairs
separated by colons that are sort of
semi secretly sent from browser to
server and from server to browser now we
more sophisticated developer types can
see this stuff right you can open up
Chrome's network tab and start poking
around in it's it's not secret per se
it's just most people don't know it's
there and what Google and other
companies are doing is they literally
send a header called set - cookie the
value of which is that big random value
that the server has decided for you your
browser assuming it speaks HTTP properly
should then save that value in RAM your
computer's memory or on your hard drive
and then every other click you make on
gmail.com should send not just headers
like this but it should send kind of the
opposite header just cookie not set
cookie but cookie which is the
presentation of that hand stamp and so
every time you click a page on Gmail or
Facebook or almost any website into
which you've logged in those cookies
have been planted on your computer now
recently in both the Europe and in the
US have laws been passed that are
increasingly putting pressure on
companies that operate internationally
to present you with cookie based
information right you get these little
pop-ups increasingly you've been getting
them for years in Europe saying are you
we can we plant cookies on your computer
so given all this what might happen if
you say no no cookies on my computer
you're gonna have to keep logging in
right if you take away this fundamental
HTTP feature much of the web breaks or
the user experience deteriorate
significantly now the flip side is
cookies can be used not only for good so
to speak but also for evil it turns out
that there's a lot of ads on
the Internet of course and that's what
drives a lot of the revenue that makes
it all possible those ads typically come
from image tags in your HTML or script
tags or some of the HTML types we have
seen in the class but they go to
third-party servers somewhere else comm
and the problem arises with cookies when
those third parties are allowed to plant
cookies on your computer because if you
go to Google and you go to Facebook and
you go to Twitter bunches of websites
suppose they all have some middleman
advertising service advertising on each
of these websites that middleman so to
speak because they have their ads and
therefore they're HTTP headers on this
site and this site in this site there
are big third parties out there lots of
them advertising networks that know
everywhere little old you is going
because they see your cookie appearing
from multiple different other sites and
so here's where cookies become not a
computer science engineering feats but
really a threat to one's privacy because
they can be used so easily for tracking
and frankly AT&T and Verizon as an aside
got into trouble though and even not
enough people know this some years back
when they started injecting forcibly
additional HTTP headers similar in
spirit to this to all of people's cell
phone traffic so not things you could
even opt out in out of initially because
this was a way to for advertisers and
for themselves to be able to track users
so these HTTP headers on which cookies
are based are very powerful but also
very invasive and we're only now
starting to see societally and
politically push back on this very
simple mechanism that hopefully we as Cs
types just understand the mechanics of
and therefore now the implications so
let's see this in context for instance
let me go ahead and open up a relatively
small example in cs50 IDE for those
unfamiliar cs50 IDE is a web based
application via which you can write
programs in the cloud just using any
browser on a Mac or PC I'm going to go
ahead and into my account here and I'm
gonna go into store and I'm going to go
into the templates directory and show
that this example here has a few files
this will look familiar to students in
the room application dot pi is the
web-based application and then we have
some template files so to speak in my
terminal window here I'm gonna go ahead
and with just my keyboard go into this
directory called store and
source 8 which is available online and
I'm going to go ahead and do flask run
which for those unfamiliar is the
command via which you can start a web
server and start running a web-based
application so now that I have that I'm
going to go ahead and visit exactly this
URL here and we'll see a relatively
simple and super ugly web's store let me
go ahead and zoom in a bit and this
webstore allows me to buy three things
whose bars and basses whatever those are
and this is a very simple ecommerce like
site where I just have to type the
quantity of foods bars and badges that I
want and then I can go ahead and buy
them so I'm gonna go ahead and say give
me one food how about zero bars and two
basses and I'm gonna go ahead and click
purchase and now you'll see my shopping
cart but if I continue shopping you'll
see that it resets just like if you keep
browsing Amazon or whatever other
website but if you want to check your
shopping cart again notice it's
remembered what I'm looking for and in
fact you know what I'm gonna go ahead
and close the window oops I actually
lost the website but you know what if I
go back to that URL and reopen I see the
storefront but if I view my shopping
cart it has remembered my state so
notice the power now of cookies it's not
just to remember with a hand stamp who
you are but now you can remember
anything about that user that you want
right a shopping cart on Amazon or any
web site it's like the best example of
this because it would be horrible
horrible horrible for a user experience
or UX if every time you click the darn
link you lost the contents of your
shopping cart cuz the website forgot who
you are so this is a compelling feature
to remember and it's cookies that
implement this feature too because more
generally what's going on with cookies
is this when you set a cookie using the
setcookie header that looked like this
there is a key value pair to the right
that we might call session and that has
the value value is the hand stamp
session is just a term of art that
refers to this abstraction that you can
think of really as a shopping cart but
it doesn't have to have anything to do
with actual shopping or e-commerce it's
just a container in which you can store
stuff so this is telling the website
that my session value my hand stamp is 1
2 3 4 5 and big really random number the
website can then say you know what I'm
gonna store
a container for you let's call it a
Python dictionary or dict for you inside
of which I can put anything I want and
so in fact when you go to a shopping
cart like this what is the server
actually doing well upon seeing your
hand stamp and realizing oh you are user
one two three four five six seven
oh that's user name Mahlon let me go
ahead and grab the dictionary the Python
dict
from memory or even from a CSV file if
you want and show you the contents of
your shopping cart meanwhile if someone
else Brian visits the same exact website
in logs in with his account he's going
to present a different hand stamp
presumably and so the website can look
for a different dictionary and show
Brian the different contents of his
shopping cart and the same for everyone
in this room so this simple mechanism I
mean consider the power this is just a
stupid text value key colon value and
from all of that does all of the web´s
capabilities now come and we won't look
in too much detail into the code here
but let me show one snippet of it if I
go into application type I the magic
that makes this possible in flask is
just to import this additional feature
you'll recall from the past couple of
problems you've worked on you import
from flask a few things render template
redirect requests well if you add
session to that list which is the code
abstraction of this hand stamp idea what
you can now do is this let me scroll
down to the juicy part here and notice
that you can do lines of code now and
for the next cs50 finance problem lines
of code like this session is just a
Python dictionary or dict you can index
into it using any word foo or bar or
bass just like you could with
dictionaries more generally and you can
store in it anything you want in my case
I want to store a number 0 Foos or 1 foo
or 2 Foos or whatever so I can simply
convert to an int the users requests
forms item whatever that is and let me
wave my hand at some of the code above
because it just kind of sets the whole
thing up but the new line of code the
new feature that now will empower us to
build something like a stock trading
website is quite simply this line here
because what you can also do to remember
that a user is logged in just go ahead
and store in this so-called session a
value of like true and if the value true
is there you can infer that the human is
logged in and if there's no such value
in the dictionary
they are not logged in and so we'll hold
your hand a bit more in the next problem
sets with this introduction of cs50
finance and we'll write some of the code
that handles the login so you can see by
example how to do this
but it'll be up to you thereafter to
start remembering what stocks a user
actually has using sessions to retain
the fact that they've logged in already
alright so that was a lot all at once
but any questions on cookies and the
feature they provide these things called
sessions how do you think you know yeah
is the session saved on the user side or
the server really good question and the
answer can be it depends you could store
it on the user's client on their browser
and as a gentleman up here proposed
earlier you could are over here proposed
you could theoretically store like
literally their username and password
maybe I proposed that earlier on their
computer and that's bad for the reasons
that we surmised earlier but you could
also store the contents of their
shopping carts whose bars and basses
that's not quite as invasive as storing
their password but if you're buying
things you don't really want people
knowing that is then invasive so maybe
we can do better and better is often
stored on the server so a well-designed
website will typically store only this
big random value the hand stamp on the
Mac or PC and then all of the
interesting and maybe sensitive stuff is
stored in a database or a CSV file or
just the server's RAM or memory like in
a global variable good question
other questions other questions
now all right so that's one problem
solved we know now we can implement
login forms and we know that we can
remember that people are logged in so
let's just stipulate that is now
possible but over the past couple of
weeks it's not been incredibly powerful
to only have access to things like CSV
files comma separated values which
create the illusion of like Excel and
Google Spreadsheets and Apple numbers
like columns and rows why well it's
pretty much linear search for everything
all right a CSV files just rows and rows
and rows and rows of data and if you
want to search for anything in that file
like you might have wanted to for your
survey implementation how do you find it
well you open the file with open you
maybe use a for loop and iterate over
every single line looking for some value
and then you close the file that is Big
O of n in the worst case the thing you
care about is at the very end and that's
not terribly efficient now you can
append two files pretty efficiently
recall that when we open files with
quote unquote
a for append mode we did this with a
brief example instead of w-4 right you
can help you get the operating systems
help and add rows to the file at the
very bottom which is more efficient but
you can't insert things in the middle
very efficiently you can't delete things
very easily you would have to literally
for those kinds of scenarios open the
file read the whole darn thing then
write out parts of it or add to it as
you're writing out and so humans years
ago realized well this is stupid all of
us humans in the world are constantly
writing code to open files change file
save files well I don't a few of us do
an even better job of implementing that
feature and then share it with the world
and thus were born effectively databases
and these days there's so many different
types of databases you might be familiar
with tools commercial software like
Oracle or sequel server or Microsoft
Access and an open source world there's
Postgres and MySQL and sequel Lite and
others and many of them has even those
names imply use a special language
called sequel structured query language
which is the very last language we'll
introduce you to in cs50 unless you go
off on your own with final projects to
pick up something more but with sequel
do you have the ability to select data
from a database to insert it to delete
it to update it all of the things that
you could absolutely do with Python and
CSVs it would just be so darn tedious to
write those lines of code yourself so
what's the right mental model here is I
essentially a database like most
everyone in this room has probably used
Google Spreadsheets and if you've not
probably Excel or maybe Apple numbers so
these are spreadsheets and they're
essentially what you could call a
relational database relational implying
that there's relationships among the
various data in the rows and the columns
decided by you or whoever made it and
this is a spreadsheet of course and it
has rows where your entity your actual
data goes and columns and what's
noteworthy about the columns
it's just conventional to do what with
the columns especially in that first row
yeah put some header values right you
could certainly put them in the left
it's just humans prefer it seems to read
top to bottom instead of left to all the
way to the right so we just adopted a
convention years ago that your columns
represent different types of data and
the rows represent different values for
those fields or for those columns so to
speak so if you wanted a store like a
spreadsheet of values for a bunch of
students in a class or in a university
one column might be ID number like their
Harvard ID or their Yale idea another
column might be their name their email
address phone number age and so forth
and you could just lay that all out you
can make it pretty in boldface the top
and organize things and sort it but at
some point this isn't quite the right
tool and in fact I ran into this in grad
school years ago where I was analyzing
large sets of data and it was just
convenient to double-click on a CSV file
open it in Excel and just manipulate it
and do answer the data questions that I
had but back in the day Excel actually
had a limit of 65536
rows sounds like a lot and that's 2 to
the 16th power if you caught the
reference there but in so humans and
Microsoft decided years ago that's
enough and frankly it kind of was
because even in the thousands of rows
like my Mac just became unusable because
there was just too much memory being
used so we said just a impractical limit
anyway but at some point you might want
to store 65,536 Google and Facebook and
others that surely do this already you
can't just use a program on your Mac or
PC anymore you need to use fancier
software but that fancier software often
still works the same way you have one
main file called a spreadsheet in our
Hume
world but in the server world you might
call it a database instead and whereas
in our human world we might have things
called sheets or individual spreadsheets
within the bigger file in a database
you're gonna have things called tables
but they're the exact same thing with
rows and columns and so when we want to
actually store data we can actually
store it in exactly those ways so let me
go ahead and do this let me go ahead and
open up Google Spreadsheets just is
representative of a database and let me
go ahead and create a new file here so
new spreadsheet and just so that we can
represent things like students I'm gonna
call this spreadsheet students and over
here I'm gonna put their ID number and
their name and what are some other
fields I rattled off where they come to
mind email say again dorm good sport ok
so sports they want to do shirt that's
fine a little longer what else
graduation your age okay good so
graduation year age concentration okay
we could probably keep going and it just
gets wider and wider and these are my my
columns if you will or the fields in the
database and you know frankly I could
name this if I really want to be tidy
here and I could call this students and
you know what maybe I should call this
not students but university because I
might want to have another tab here that
all will preemptively name to say
faculty and faculty probably have ID
numbers and they have names and they
probably have departments for instance
and they also probably have emails and
so forth so I'm your phone numbers
another one but I might want to kind of
cluster these different types of data in
different spreadsheets because they're
kind of apples and oranges there might
be some overlap but they're distinct and
so I different sheets in the database
world you do the exact same thing except
you call the whole thing a database and
you call these things tables to be
cleared but more importantly with a real
database so to speak you have to be a
little more proactive about telling the
database what types of data you want to
store now those of you have used Google
Spreadsheets and Apple numbers in Excel
know that you can go to like the format
menu or the data menu or whatever and
you can show things to different decimal
places you can turn things to percents
and you can format the data but that
doesn't tend to have any functional
impact on your data it's just an
aesthetic detail like
how long or short do you want to show
the numbers to be in your columns and
cells but with databases you can
actually provide juicy hints to the
database that will help that database
store and find data for you more
efficiently for instance there's this
laundry list of data types to which we
have access in sequel so sequel is the
language with which we're going to be
able to query a database frankly in
something like google spreadsheets and
microsoft excel how do you find data
we'll usually hit like command F or
control F and you search for that's not
very programmatic you can do it with
macros and such and we'll do this with
code but with sequel you're gonna have
to make a few decisions first sequel
supports a few different data types at
least in one of its form so it turns out
there's a lot of competition out there
sequel is a general language with
different companies and different
nonprofit groups have come up with their
own dialects so much like we humans
might speak and bunches of us might
speak Spanish well there's different
variations of Spanish not to mention
many many many other languages and so
similarly in the programming world is
there sort of a common subset of words
in a language but then different
companies and different people might
have added and subtracted their own
features just because they think that's
better for their use cases so in sequel
Lite which is the database technology we
will use in cs50 IDE and Android uses
this and it's very popular in other
contexts to iOS as well they only have a
few data types blob of all things
integer numeric real and txt now what
does that mean well it turns out it
means different things with different
databases and another popular database
is called Postgres or Postgres sequel
this is a very popular one for
high-performing websites so if you're
trying to build a business you're trying
to make an application used by everyone
on campus generally you would use a
fancier technology than sequel Lite
which is by definition lightweight and
you do something like Postgres and so
we'll introduce you to both of these
dialects along the way because each of
them allows us to do different things
with a different degree of precision so
in sequel let's claim even though it's a
simplification there are at least these
data types when deciding what type of
data to store in your database table you
have to decide not just what it's called
like ID and name and email and dorm you
have to decide what data type it is so
we've kind of come full circle because
the last time we did this was in what
language
see so in sequel to you do this but it's
not to be nitpicky it's to actually
improve performance so this is to help
you get at that data more efficiently
because the more the server the database
knows about your data
the faster can find it essentially so in
the world of databases you generally
have to decide not just to store an
integer but either a small ant of an
integer or a big int and generally
speaking at least in most databases this
might be 2 bytes this might be 4 bytes
this might be 8 bytes so let's maybe
impress the families here if you have a
32-bit integer or 4 bytes what's the
biggest integer you can store in your
database someone plays impressed 4
billion is exactly correct and it might
be four billion positive values or maybe
it's only two billion if you also want
to have 2 billion or so negative numbers
as well
big int uses 64 bits which is just
massively massively bigger and tiny int
or small in try there's also tiny int in
some dialects small integers 2 bytes and
it actually counts up as high as 65535
as I alluded to earlier so you just need
to decide now why would you choose one
over the other when you could just use
big int and store small numbers and big
numbers alike well why might you just
intuitively not want to make all of your
integer values in a database begins it's
just simple give me as much Headroom as
I want you're just using memory
unnecessarily right why use more memory
than you need to now arguably got memory
so cheap these days computers are
getting bigger and faster so in some
contexts it's not a big deal but if you
have lots of data and every one of your
rows in a database is 2 bytes bigger
than it needs to be and you have a
million rows I mean that's already huge
numbers of bytes that you're just
wasting and throwing away so it behooves
you to actually give some thought to
these data types of course you don't
want to go too small because if you use
a small inch or maybe even an integer
but business is so darn good that you
have over 4 billion users or 4 billion
rows or 4 billion foods and bars and
basses that have been sold which
absolutely happens to the googles and
Facebooks of the world
you better start using 64 bits to
represent unique values and
of just 32 because eventually you'll run
out well what else besides integer
values in sequel you might want to use
floating-point values those are real
numbers that have decimal points in them
this is quite like C they're called a
little something different and knowingly
it uses two words in this case but a
real number is a 32-bit value that is a
floating-point value like a float in C
and double precision is like a double in
C which is 64 bits and that just lets
you get even finer grained control over
the decimal point as we've seen because
of course you can't represent numbers
precisely because of imprecision as
we've seen in both Python and C numeric
is kind of a catch-all for a bunch of
number related things that aren't quite
integers or reals necessarily boolean a
true or false value dates if you want to
literally store like year year year year
- month month - day day and a standard
computer format even though human
cultures vary how they write that date
time if you want to have a date and a
time right after it numeric is actually
a solution to a problem turns out that
finally after all this time we have a
built in mechanism for storing numbers
precisely and this is perfectly time
because in cs50 finance when you're
dealing with money
it kind of be nice if you don't
accidentally round off how much money
someone has either slightly lower
slightly higher those of you maybe
families especially because from a few
movies back in the day if you ever saw
Superman 3 this is how some money was
made by shaving fractions of pennies off
of computer systems and more modern Lee
office space office space did this as
well big scam trying to round off these
pennies well you if you use the right
technology and language with sequel you
can actually specify a numeric data type
which is like a floating point value but
you specify essentially the total number
of digits you want to handle and how
many of them should be after the decimal
point so it's common in stock markets to
actually use four decimal points of
precision so not just sense by to the
tense in the hundreds place but to the
thousands and ten thousands place you
can now specify that with a value of
four for precision and you don't have to
worry about those roundoff area errors
we've talked about before time and time
stamps just how much time has passed
since a gate in date and time are also
available to you in sequel and then
lastly here text values turns out you
have a choice of values for when it calm
to deciding how many characters to use
to store your data you can use char
which just like in C with an array you
have to decide in advance for a string
how many bytes to use and if you say
char 8 you are getting 8 bytes and if
the name is male and ma LAN you are
wasting 3 or if we know terminate it 2
of those bytes but sequel introduces a
solution that Python kind of gave us 2
varchar' as the name kind of implies
variable number of chars allows you to
specify just an upper bound so if you
know that one of your columns is going
to be called name and a person's name
might be mal ant like 5 letters or maybe
certainly more for people with longer
last names or first names you can say
var char a hundred and that's the upper
bound on how long it is but the database
will be smart if you only need 5
characters or 5 bytes it won't waste 95
others for you it will optimize that for
you
and then lastly text if you want to
store tens of thousands like paragraphs
or pages of text that's even bigger than
varchar' where you don't necessarily
want a well-defined upper bound you just
want a good chunk of memory but there's
implications here and just quickly char
and varchar' seem like not even
complimentary just char seems
unnecessary why paint yourself into a
corner and say give me only 8 bytes when
you could just say give me up to 100
bytes and you the database server figure
out how many to actually use like why do
these two data types exist yeah time
yeah so time is spot on it might
actually take longer to use one data
type or the other how could that
possibly be well if you've got a value
like char where you specify a precise
number of characters like 8 if you think
about the columns in Google Spreadsheets
in Excel every one of those columns that
cells is exactly the same width right
it's 8 bytes
8 bytes 8 bytes 8 bytes and as soon as
you have perfectly constant offsets this
is byte 0 this is 8 this is 16 this is
24 this is 32 and so forth you
reintroduce the capability that in C we
had with arrays you have random access
doing simple simple arithmetic
multiplication addition and subtraction
you can just jump to any element in a
column if it's using the same number of
bytes for every
CEL but with varchar' if you need to
have small very narrow caught cells and
wide cells you're gonna have what's
called a ragged array where one side of
it the left-hand side so to speak is
going to be very straight and rigid but
the other side might kind of vary based
on how long the word is in that column
and to your point about time it's gonna
take the computer more time to search a
varchar' field because it can't just
jump to the third element it has to
search all of them potentially but
thankfully at the end of the day
databases don't do that they don't just
evolve until linear search CSV is to
resolve for our purposes into linear
search the magic and the sort of
intellectual property and the secret
sauce so to speak that goes into
databases Oracle sequel server Microsoft
Access Postgres by sequel and sequel
light is that really smart computer
scientists have decided to implement
algorithms and fancy data structures
often tree based if you recall our
discussion of binary trees or tries on
hash tables and those fancier data
structures they have baked those kinds
of data structures and designs into
their database software they've made it
freely available or commercially
available and so we now just have an
abstraction called the database into
which we can store data and just read it
update it write it and change it quickly
without having to implement all of that
low-level plumbing ourselves and so
that's ultimately what a database is
going to give us but we have to actually
have access to a database to do that and
we need to actually decide first to help
the database by telling it what to store
where and how to store it as a type so
why don't we do this let me go ahead and
do exactly that with a couple of
examples let me go ahead and open up
cs50 IDE again our web-based programming
environment and let me go into our
terminal window so for those unfamiliar
terminal window is just this black and
white or this blue and white window in
which you can type commands and rather
than point and click and double click on
things you can only do things textually
in this window and it turns out that in
the world of sequel light we can
actually use a command called sequel
light 3 which allows us to create a
database so in our human worlds for CSV
you've seen how in code you can just
create rows and columns you can
literally type it in a text box sequel
light and is a database technology that
uses binding
format zeroes and ones and so you're
gonna have to actually store your data
differently using a program so if I want
to make a file called for instance frosh
IMS DB I can literally say sequel like
three frosh IMS DB and then I'm in this
program this is a text based program via
which I can create my rows and columns
and it by design is gonna be a little
arcane for a moment it's gonna look a
little cryptic but if I want to go ahead
and create a table like a spreadsheet in
here I'm gonna literally type create
table I'm gonna call this registrants
just like last week when we were looking
at frosh IMS examples in the freshmen
intramural sports program has kids
students registering for sports so I'm
gonna have a registrants table here I'm
gonna go ahead now and specify that I
want a few columns for this database
table one of which I want to call ID one
of which I want to call name and one of
which I want to call dorm so I'm gonna
keep ups I didn't mean to hit enter let
me just clean this up so now I have
three columns ID name and dorm and if I
were to hit enter theoretically it
should create a database it's not going
to be graphical like Excel or Google
Spreadsheets but it will exist in my IDE
in a file called frosh IMS dB but I
can't just hit enter yet because I have
to tell the database a bit more I need
to tell it that you know what my ID
value should probably be an integer and
you know what my name should probably be
char var char
what should the name of a student be
stored as varchar'
okay so varchar' because they're gonna
vary right if you can think of bunches
of your friends they might have short
names or long names
okay what's the upper bound what's the
length of your friends your friends
longest name 16 huh is anyone in here
having a name first name and last that's
longer than 16 good Oh 50 sorry I heard
16 I thought because you're not gonna be
able to register for frosh IMS because
the database is gonna truncate it and as
an aside if you've ever gone to a
website and tried typing into a form
field and either your keyboard stops
working or you do type a long word or
paragraph in and then you hit Enter and
it's some of it's gone well that's
because the database likely can only
store so many bytes and frankly this
often happens on customer service forums
right if they don't really want you
being too verbose with the customer
support staff they'll cap the length of
the field
into which you're typing and they're
also doing that on the database but also
probably for practical human reasons
they don't want to read a big complaint
that's this long as well so 50 anyone
have a name longer than 50 characters
and Turkey and not many names but you
know what's there we have technology to
answer this longest name in world and
it's this guy Guinness Book of World
Records is probably right so his name is
Barnaby Marmaduke alloy sis Benji cobweb
d'Artagnan Egbert Felix Gasper Humbert
Ignatius Jayden Casper Leroy Maximilian
Eddie vigillo a Pepin quill um
Rosencrantz Sexton Teddy up wood viv
atma Wayland Xylon Yardley Zachary who
sanski but he also goes by Nick
apparently but okay let me go ahead and
highlight this and I just I could count
this manually but I'm sure someone has
made a website to count characters in a
string there we go letter count com
okay let's go ahead and paste that in
count the characters 225 so Nick will
not be registering unless we don't
support just 16 or 50 looks like we need
at least 225 so at some point you do
have to make a decision and honestly
it's not always obvious you do have to
specify that varchar' is gonna be could
be 16 could be 50 could be 225 but you
know what he has kids so let's just
round up a bit and call it varchar' 255
honestly only because it was a
convention so back in the day 255 tended
to be the max length for this field in
older databases and that at least feels
like it's probably enough wiggle room
for names but you have to make a
judgment call at some point we could
ignore the problem and say a thousand
characters but if that's never really
gonna happen in your potentially wasting
space you probably shouldn't because
even though it's an upper bound you're
sacrificing something like time
potentially to search that field if
you're just telling the database that
it's going to be bigger than it ever
actually will be it needs to be more
finely hinted so what about dorm oh god
now we have to do this again how do we
do it with dorm what's the longest
length of a dorm or a house on campus I
like her for Siemer house maybe but you
know honestly at some point
doesn't matter too much but being
consistent is what matters it's a matter
of style it's a matter of design at some
point you know you don't have to nitpick
every little value but you should
probably pick some reasonable value that
you could justify to a roommate or to a
colleague or to a Teaching Fellow and
then say this feels like enough without
it being actually excessive and there's
one last thing I'm gonna do here is just
end my thought with a semicolon
I apologize they're back but at the end
of my start here if I haven't made any
type of graphical errors and I'm gonna
go ahead and hit enter nothing seems to
happen and ironically in cs50 and
programing nothing happening is usually
a good thing because it means no errors
have happened if in sequel light I type
schema I can actually just see a regular
Gurjit ation of the table I just created
but more importantly I can start to
insert data into this now unfortunately
it's not yet graphical but if I want to
insert data into this I can do this
insert into registrants well what do you
want to insert I want to go ahead and
insert an ID a name and a dorm well with
what values well with these values the
ID will be the first registrant will be
one the first one to register will be
Brian and his dorm brine where'd you
live Pennypacker so it's good that might
be close to for time or two lengthwise
so I'm gonna go ahead and do this here
is an example of a sequel statements
create table is one verb or expression
you can use insert into is another you
specify the name of the table the fields
of the table and then values and now I'm
capitalizing just to make clear what our
sequel commands and what are actually
just words I the human developer chose
but it's just a convention these upper
case words could probably be lowercase
in most contexts too but it helps things
I think visually to distinguish now I go
ahead and hit enter nothing seemed to
happen that's probably a good thing
let's go ahead and register one other
person I'll be the second registrant so
maybe David from Matthews and so
Matthews here enter and now if I want to
select all of the students in the
database I can go ahead and say select
from or you know what let's select
everything as denoted in many languages
by star from registrants semicolon enter
and there we have it it's kind of a tiny
super simple lightweight database but
there are my rows and columns much like
Excel when Google Spreadsheets would lay
them out for me but it gets better than
this suppose I want to search this
database for all of the students who
registered for Matthews and suppose that
time passes and more students actually
register for frosh Iams I can actually
filter this data I can do something like
select star from registrants where dorm
equals quote unquote Matthews and so I
can filter it hit enter and now I get
back just one row and if you should mind
starts to wander wow if I could
introduce Python or JavaScript into this
you know what I could do I could
probably get back not this this
ascii-based table this text table maybe
I could get back an actual list of rows
so that I can actually do something with
that data and that's indeed where we're
going with this so if I want to select
someone else I could do him maybe select
just the name from registrants where
dorm equals Matthews if I only care
about knowing who registered I could do
that and Whittle it down to even less
data so he already in just these few
commands I can express so much more
functionality than you could with a CSV
to do this in CSV you would have had to
write all of these lines of Python code
yourself what if Brian moved so Brian
really didn't like the Union dorm so
we're gonna go ahead and update
registrants and set dorm equal to where
do you want to move to Canada where I
could do this a few ways what's your
instinct how could identify Brian and
only Brian so I don't want to move to
Canada how do we move just Brian yeah
maybe we could do up swear name equals
quote unquote Brian and enter I like
this but someone find fault with this if
you could if there's two Brian's we're
moving both of them are all three of
them so baby better honestly would be to
say let's just say where the ID equals
one now of course I know you know
Brian's Harvard ID number or whatnot but
this is going to be more precise because
the supposition here is that the
leftmost column our ID field by human
convention should be unique so that it
uniquely identifies the room so we can
have as many Brian's as we want but
we're not going to confuse them if I go
ahead and hit enter now nothing seems to
happen but if I select star from
registrants again and hit enter notice
now Brian has indeed been moved
kanaday so there's so many other things
Bryant you know what you're not very
good at sports the team concluded so
delete from registrants we're ID equals
one and now if we select star from
registrants we have I guess just me left
but Brian is gone as well so we have the
ability to insert to select to update
and delete and create all the while
while filtering and we've only just
scratched the surface here of what's
possible because it turns out we can
store so much data in these databases
all of our students all of our faculty
if you're a company you can start to
store all of the products in your
database all of the orders all of your
customers but as soon as you start going
down that road we'll see what's a
customer customers have names and ID
numbers and maybe email addresses and
postal addresses those are gonna get
messy phone numbers which are kind of
like integers but not quite so there's
so many questions we still need to
answer but feels like it's time for some
fruit and some muffins so why don't we
go ahead and take a five-minute break
turn on some music parents need to
depart that's fine and we'll see you
back here in five or so minutes all
right so we're back and where we left
off was exactly here using sequel Lite 3
which is version 3 of the sequel Lite
command which is just in text based
interface to the technology that we
should think of as sequel Lite sequel
Lite is interesting in its light weight
in the sense that it's not a server it's
not fancy software that you have to run
it literally stores all of your data in
a file but that by convention ends in
dot DB or maybe even dot sequel Lite but
it's just a binary file zeros and ones
it's not text that you can open with
Excel or something like that so it's not
a CSV so it's stored on file this means
that you don't need this particular
experience with setting up a database
server you don't need memory and
software to actually run on the computer
you can store everything locally but you
do pay a price because recall from our
past discussions disks are slow and if
you're storing your data on the disk
it's not going to be nearly as fast as
storing it only in RAM and that's why
these other technologies like Postgres
in my sequel and Microsoft Access and
sequel server and oracle exist those are
fancier products where someone literally
does double click an icon or run a
command that runs a program that stays
running in the computer's memory and
gives you even better performance but
for our purposes pedagogically sequel
Lite is handy but we're still going to
ask
about data types because sequel light
does support fancier data types like
those in Postgres and sequel server and
MySQL and Oracle and those are the
lowercase ones we introduced a bit ago
but honestly this is going to get
tedious quickly like even I rarely
remember exactly the right syntax when
creating tables the order in which
everything has to go so I tend to use a
graphical user interface or GUI myself
and there's lots of tools out there but
we've built one that's free and open
source into cs50 IDE that just makes it
a little easier to edit your sequel
tables so I'm going to go ahead and exit
out of sequel Lite whoops exit out of
sequel Lite and I'm going to go ahead
over here and you'll notice that we have
all of the files from today including
most recently frosh IMS DB that is the
file I created with sequel Lite 3 but if
you double click it
when using cs50 IDE it's actually going
to open a program that's called PHP
lighted min it happens to be written in
another language called PHP has nothing
to do with databases just the name of
the product here but it's a tool that
using pretty simple HTML tables just
gives us a graphical user interface over
the exact same functionality and
personally I just find this easier to
use and pedagogically it's gonna be
better because it's going to show us the
available data types for our table so
for instance notice here there's a lot
going on on the screen but a lot of this
is just uninteresting details but notice
here I see a table called registrants
and then I can browse it I can see its
structure I can execute manual sequel by
typing it in I can search it insert I
can do bunches of things to it and
that's why this graphical user interface
is just convenient let me go ahead and
click on registrants and by default I
will see these tabs now browse structure
sequel and then a bunch of others and
notice over here you'll see the one row
and the one registrants because when we
last left off we removed Brian forcibly
from the team so suppose I want to go
ahead and add more rows just for the
sake of discussion I can just do it
manually here I can go in here and I can
say let's say the third player is gonna
be for Veronica I think she was also in
Matthews so I can just type that in here
and I can just go ahead and click insert
but what's nice about PHP lighted man is
that it will not only insert the rows
for you it will show you
the sequel like code with which you
could have done it yourself so it's a
nice visual reinforcement over that
exact same command and you'll notice
they use double quotes instead of my
single quotes before there's sometimes
interchangeable but not always so it's a
wonderful way of just learning how you
can actually do this with the right
sequel code so you're not
oversimplifying it with the GUI but you
know what let's do this I'm gonna go
ahead and start over because I want to
make some better decisions I'm gonna go
ahead and literally right-click or ctrl
click this delete frosh IMS DB and let's
actually start this from scratch now
previously when I did this I could have
in my terminal window gone ahead and
done sequel Lite 3 and then what was at
frosh IMS dot DB and created the file
for now I'm going to actually just go
ahead and touch a file called that name
which is a simple command that just
literally creates it but puts nothing in
it just so I have an empty file and
you'll see that it just popped up again
on the left hand side which is handy and
now I can double click this version of
it which has nothing in it yet and I'm
back to PHP light admin but notice no
table in database so let's start to ask
some of the harder questions as to
actually how to create data in a
database so let me go ahead and go to
this fields here create new table on
database frosh IMS I'll go ahead and
call it registrants again but how many
fields so let's go with ID name and dorm
what else
email I heard earlier age I heard
earlier sometimes as far as do you want
excuse me sports you want to be in ok
six fields six fields let's go with that
so it's actually you know seven fields I
want phone numbers too this time so let
me go ahead and click go and now you'll
see just a GUI way of prompting you for
all the answers to the same questions as
before and maybe this is clear maybe
it's not but it's just an alternative to
the memorizing exactly what the commands
need to be so top to bottom here's all
of the fields I need to decide on
ironically the fields is just a synonym
for columns and yet my columns are
currently laid out in rows but that's
just a UI issue so let me go ahead and
decide by convention my first field is
almost always ID or probably should be
and we'll see why this is powerful in
just a little bit the datatype for that
by convention should be integer unless
you've got a lot of data like a Facebook
and then big int make more sense but
notice this drop-down actually gives us
a nice
you of options just as before and you'll
see in gray text the category or in
fancy terms the affinity of these
various types in sequel light and in
lowercase black words here you'll see
the actual datatype supported by big
popular databases like Postgres that you
might want to use for your final
projects in fact we're introducing these
when the night or you're using these for
final projects in the cloud not in cs50
ide but actually getting your own domain
name and putting your website if you do
a web app out there so here we have all
of my available types and under integer
I'm gonna go ahead and literally choose
integer for my ID alright next go ahead
and zoom out let me go ahead and choose
a student's name before did we do did we
decide on char of our char
okay bar char in what size 255 so the
user interface here just allows me to
type it in so the syntax is a little
different because it's a GUI but 255 but
you know what the last field was dorm
that too I think we said varchars so let
me choose that and 255 though this one's
a little more debatable I'm not sure
what the right number is so in the
absence of clarity I'm just going to
standardize on some same value without
being too wasteful but notice there's a
few questions here that we haven't come
to but our perfect segue earlier hinted
at this it turns out you need to make a
few other decisions when designing a
database if you know in advance that one
of your fields is like the primary piece
of data to uniquely identify users
that's what's gonna be called a primary
key the column or field that guaranteed
is going to identify users uniquely so
if you've got two Brians
each of them is gonna have its own ID
that therefore is your primary key not
the name field Brian so I'm gonna tell
the database this is the primary key and
it's gonna help me keep track of that
uniqueness moreover this is a fancy
feature before I was manually and very
arbitrarily saying Brian will be number
one I'll be number two Veronica will be
number three that's tedious like
computers should be able to solve that
problem for me I don't want to think
about who is ID number what you can auto
increment the field so if I actually
check this box sequel for me will just
plus plus plus plus the ID field every
time an cert a new name and a new dorm I
don't have to even bother specifying an
ID anymore now there's another column
here not null where you can specify this
column should never be null and this is
important because if you're building a
website
that has important data that you must
have from the users like your app won't
work without the users use a username or
their password of their email address
you can say not null and your database
will ensure that you can't even insert a
row into this database unless you give
it a value for that field so it helps
you protect you against yourself because
you could certainly implement that
logically in Python or any language but
the database is a final gauntlet as well
a default value doesn't really make
sense here but for certain types of
fields you can say database insert the
current time or the current date for me
now why might you want that why date and
time by default well I might that be
useful when the account was created when
they bought a foo when they shipped the
bar any number of reasons you might just
want to know what is the time right now
we don't have to write code for that the
database can answer those questions for
you so just so much more functionality
than we got of course with CSVs alone so
name should it be a primary key no
otherwise we couldn't have two Brians
and generally your primary key will be
one field though theoretically you could
make joint columns if you wanted but
generally it'll be a single one should
we auto increment Brian so it's like
well we had Brian 28 or Brian - Brian 3
and so forth
no doesn't really make sense not null
probably I want all of the freshman's
names so that we know who is signing up
for sports and dorm yet not know but
whole corner case can anyone think of a
corner case where dorm maybe should kind
of sort of be null the commute their
off-campus you know it's not many
students but if you have one percent
five percent of students living off
campus this is a design question now and
you all of us have probably visited some
website where you just can't fill out
the form in the right way because you
don't fit their mold or their
expectations and that's just because of
a poor design decision so let's allow it
to be null just in case now what else we
said a phone number was one I proposed
gosh there's no fun phone number type so
what do you want to go with
I'm sorry varchar' okay so we can pick
varchar' and maybe use like ten or so
for ten digits in the u.s. at least
though maybe like 12 with the dashes or
13 with the parenthesis or what's that I
hear murmuring
a small int and just treat it as a
number maybe that could work too another
alternative anything else a precision so
specific number good so not a bad
instinct but it turns out with the
numeric data type where you have specify
scale as it's called the total number of
digits and precision
that's all that's generally meant for
floating-point value so real numbers
with decimal points because even though
you're specifying a max limit you don't
require that many digits it's just a max
yeah
yeah we can kind of find faults I think
in both of these ideas but both of them
are reasonable if you allow for char or
varchar I could type in like foo or bar
or Baz and not a number so maybe we
should go with int but can someone think
of a counter example to why you
shouldn't use integer variable length
but if we actually do the math maybe 65
maybe there's enough bytes there or we
could use a big int and that gives us a
really long phone number so there's
probably a reasonable max yeah yeah
hyphens and parentheses we have to
decide do we want on support those and
honestly all of us are perhaps a little
us-centric right now but I wrote most of
us here but you know when you make a
local call in some zones like you type 0
first and some human might type 0 as
their number but what's gonna happen if
you type 0 into an integer field you're
gonna ignore it so now we're there's
that corner case whoo damn it like
there's no way to solve this problem it
would seem so what's best we have to
make a compromise and just accept that
we have to solve this with code varchar'
all right so varchars or char all right
so let's maybe let's simplify the
problem no one from outside the US can
take freshmen intramural sports that
simplifies the world because if we only
support us phone numbers now we can say
10 digits and if we say you know what I
don't care about the hyphens or the
parentheses I can use code JavaScript or
Python to throw away the syntax and I
can just store 10 digits maybe char 10
is sufficient 3 for the area code then
the rest of the number the all seven
digits thereof but you could find fault
with this too and we're really alienated
the international population on campus
and so but again these are just
non-obvious design decisions and so here
we are at the end of the semester we
don't always have good answers and
reasonable people will disagree but let
me simplify our assumptions and just do
us numbers 10 digits and trust that I
will use code in Python or some other
language to throw away the syntax the
punctuation and whatnot of parentheses
and hyphens and I'll make sure the human
hasn't typed in any letters of the
alphabet I can do that in code and you
know we can do that even in JavaScript
when the human submits a form let's uh
we'll leave for the end sports what was
a sports
okay sports they might want to do so
this is a good example of you shouldn't
really have spaces in your fieldname so
the convention would be sports they
really or might or let's just call it
sports in this case we'll come back to
that I think there were two other ideas
we had phone number email ok email is a
good one what should that one be there's
no email type unfortunately even though
there is an HTML an input type for email
what's that bark yeah Bart I feel like
we probably need avatar here and but
here a little non-obvious what is the
longest email address in the world
maybe it's Nixon yeah Nick so I I don't
know but let's pick a reasonable upper
bound that we can maybe be comfortable
with as a group and let's see anything
else here no ok and then which there one
more field Oh grant oh and I by age
let's go with age so age finally
something simple what do you want this
to be small in price you're not gonna
you can if we will not support people
older than 65 thousand five hundred
thirty-five years old someone want to
find fault with this idea though
I would argue there's no one right
answer to any of these month all but I
know it depends
do we want month
so you're assuming we want birthdate I
think I've called it age so maybe that's
the problem
like if it's age small it's fine like
you can be zero years old or 65 thousand
years old we have a good range if it's
age I think we're okay but I think you
lewd to a good point which is why would
we maybe want to store birth date and
not age the damn thing is always
changing otherwise right like I'm gonna
have to update my database tomorrow and
then the next day let alone every hour
or every minute just because my users
ages are changing like that seems silly
let me instead fix a value so do
something like birth date birth date
maybe specify not an int but let's
actually use the date field not time we
could store time if we really care what
time they were born on a certain day but
here I can say date is gonna be a little
better because now I know in Python
JavaScript even C I can do a little bit
of math and if I know they were born on
such-and-such a day and month and year
well I'll just subtract that from the
current day month and year and figure
out how many days or years old they are
so a better design decision there
perhaps but we do have to standardize
the formats we can't just allow people
from the US and Europe and Asia to all
kind of choose their own formats sequel
standardizes this year year year year -
month month - Day Day and that's the
value of having these datatypes again
alright so how about sports the last one
varchar' alright what's the longest
number of words in the sports they're
very athletic yeah I hear or - I don't
know but just for the sake of opening up
possibilities when you think the human
might be a little expository and
actually write a paragraph of all the
sports they're involved in or whatnot or
even bigger than a paragraph text is
even bigger sports this probably isn't
compelling and I'll change it back to
varchar' but if someone is typing in
like their college essay into the common
application or if you're asking people
to paste their resumes or the like you
might want to use text because I have no
idea how many words someone's gonna have
text allows you to store even more data
but it stores it a little differently it
tends to store it not in the column but
using pointers if you recall for
a few weeks back it uses the equivalent
of that to store it like over there
which takes a little more time to get to
so again there's just a trade-off here
so we could do varchar' 255 makes me a
little nervous so I'm gonna go with
another common value 1024 it's a power
of two but there's no one right answer
here but these are the non-obvious
design decisions we have to make if I
didn't make any mistakes here I'm gonna
go ahead and click create and who table
has been created you can even see now
all of the data that's been created
there and voila if I go back to frosh
IMS and I go back to the registrants
table not only can i browse it there's
nothing in there yet I can look at the
structure and actually see all of those
same values and edit some of them like
renaming but you can't completely
mutilate it you might have to start over
it's if you make too many changes all
right any questions then about this yeah
water is 1024 instead of 10 23 typically
when you choose a mat Oh convention I
can't justify this 255 was the max
because I think one of the bytes was
reserved for some value historically but
that's not really the case that bound
has been lifted and no good reason the
nowadays yes back if years ago 255 was
in actual limits and so it got adopted
now I don't know I just picked powers of
two off and out and then my next go-to
would be 2048 4096 and so forth
just because yeah bar chart what's the
difference between bar char and char
char uses a fixed number of bytes no
matter how many of them you are using
the advantage of which is your columns
conceptually are perfectly straight on
both the left edge and the right edge
which means you have random access
because every cell is some fixed number
of bytes from the rest varchar' uses
with like a ragged arrays it's called
where one side the right-hand side is
shorter or longer in different cells so
there's only a maximum length on each of
those cells but searching it can be
slower as a result because you can't
just jump to cell to cell you have to
follow the lengths of those things
that's the trade-off yeah
hello if I wanted to add the education
education field now and modify the table
if you realize too late ho darn like I
need to actually add something to this
in the GUI tool we can add one fields to
the end of the table literally so let's
do that let me go ahead and click go
I'll be prompted with a similar form but
smaller I can go ahead and type in
something like education let me propose
this is varchar' maybe 255 that we could
have that debate too I'm gonna go ahead
and say add fields and now notice that
the table has been altered successfully
it actually it's for whatever reason
it's not showing me the code for that
particular command but there's literally
an altar command in sequel that would
allow you to change it and if I go back
to the structure now you'll see that I
have another column called education
shown ironically here is a row yeah good
question does the order of the columns
matter fundamentally no by convention
you would typically put the ID first and
then I personally by design put like the
most important fields next like name
feels like the right choice maybe email
feels like the right choice though I
clearly thought a bit a little too late
this time
it's not easy in sequel Lite to reorder
things but in other databases you can so
there it's more of a human convention oh
yeah good question is it a convention
have one single primary key or can you
have multiple by definition you can only
have one but that primary key can span
multiple columns so we haven't seen a
use case for this yet
but there are scenarios in which you
would want to say I want to guarantee
that these two columns together are
unique but not each individual one
unique but we won't can counter that
just yet other questions yeah
really good question what if you had
added education after you already had
real data in there but you specified not
null which is problematic because what
is the educational backgrounds of the
previous people typically what the
database would do is either reject it or
it would just put the empty string
quote-unquote so it's not technically no
but there's nothing actually there it's
just a string of length zero really good
question
all right so what can we now do that's a
little more powerful about this well let
me go ahead and quickly insert some data
here I'm gonna keep most of it blank but
you know what I'm not even gonna bother
with ID Brian you're back on the team
let's go ahead and insert Brian let's go
ahead now into registrants again let's
go ahead and add Veronica again so I'm
just inserting a few rows manually and
again notice it's executing all of this
for me without me having to bother
typing it out but I absolutely could in
fact just for good measure let's do one
manually if I click the sequel tab
notice that I get a default suggestion
here that is the syntax with which you
can select everything or I can just type
in insert into registrants but now if I
only want to insert a name I don't have
to do all all of the columns I can just
say go ahead and insert here Aaron for
instance semicolon zoom out and click go
that seemed to work if I go back to
browse now Aaron is in there as well but
you'll see the difference the query
that's being generated automatically by
the GUI was lazily just inserting
quote/unquote this will called empty
string of length zero I by omitting even
mention of those columns was
deliberately inserting null so frankly
my database is getting a little messy
here so you generally don't use PHP
lited mint or GUI to insert data you
might use it to conveniently create your
tables and kind of get your application
ready but then you're gonna write code
ultimately and that's the direction
we're going I'm gonna go ahead and
insert one more person oh I forgot I'm
not on the team at all because we
started over so let me put myself back
on the team David and let me go ahead
and click insert go back to registrants
and now you'll see there's four of us my
ID change because they've been inserted
in different orders but notice all of
the auto incrementing has been happening
magically for me and that's useful
because I don't have to even think about
and who cares what my idea is I just
need to have in many cases in a database
a unique ID so now let's actually write
a little
of code right nuts far we haven't done
anything useful we've shown you like
this black and white window in which you
can like select insert and update data
but that doesn't really solve any
problems we know about yet we have this
graphical web based interface via which
you can create tables and add data but
who cares
we're trying to solve actual problems
and the problems of late have been to
build software that would solve any
number of human problems like surveying
users and showing the results or finding
similarities and documents so suppose
the problem at hand now is to actually
build something like the frosh IMS
website and let students register and
then see who is registered well back in
my day I fairly lazily for lack of
technical know-how just email to the
registrations to the proctor or the RA
who was managing the intramural sports
program but I they later started putting
it in CSV files
suppose now Version three twenty years
later I want to store it in an actual
database how can I actually do that and
then see the results well let me go into
the IDE again and open up for instance a
new file that I'll go ahead and call
lecture dot pi and suppose I just want
to write a simple Python program via
which to select data from a database so
it turns out I can do a few things here
first of all let me go ahead and do
let's say from cs50 I previously have
done things like import get string and
get int and so forth it turns out that
the cs50 library for Python also
supports sequel and it's going to give
us a function called execute that will
let you execute any sequel command but
in Python code so instead of pulling up
sequel like three move via my own hands
or going to a graphical user interface
PHP lighted man I can write code that
talks directly to frosh IMS DB and
eliminate all of those tools altogether
and just now write code so how do I do
this I'm gonna declare a variable called
DB for database that I could call it
anything I want and I'm gonna go ahead
and call this sequel function and I'm
gonna pass in a somewhat funky looking
string as an argument but it's a
standard convention to say what database
technology do you want to use then you
do colon slash slash slash so it's three
slashes not the usual two in a URL and
I'm gonna spay specify frosh IMS dot DB
this now will give me a Python variable
called database that is kind of like a
portal if you will into that database
file that I can send selects and inserts
and deletes and updates to how do I do
this well if at the end of the day I
want to execute the equivalent of select
star from registrants how do I do that
well I'm just in a text editor right
this is cs50 IDE I'm just typing text
moreover I'm typing text in a Python
file and this is not Python and indeed
the IDE has this little red X saying you
can't do this but I could pass sequel
code as an input to a Python function
and let that function talk to the
database and indeed that's what we're
gonna get here from cs50 library I'm
gonna go ahead and do this you know what
access the database and execute the
following sequel code quote-unquote that
close parenthesis now what is select
return by convention what should it
return well in in sequel Lite 3 we just
saw a kind of a pretty text-based
table right with like lines and slashes
that look like a table but it was just
text PHP lited min we actually saw HTML
tables when I browse the database and I
proposed verbally a bit ago that you
know what if I were to get back all this
data in code what data type would I like
it to be handed to me as no Rose I want
rose from a table show me all the
students who've registered what data
structure in Python seems act just a
list right a list that's ordered from
first row to last row so we'll call that
a list or an array back in the day of C
so you know what I'm gonna assume that's
correct and if I read the documentation
I would see that it's correct cs50
execute function if you select returns
to a list of rows it might have 0 rows
if there's no matches but it might have
a thousand rows if there's lots of
matches I'm going to store those results
whatever they are in my rows array now
suppose I want to print out who has
registered in my database from whatever
frosh IMS website exists I'm assuming
students have registered on the web now
I'm just the proctor or the RA who's
actually now trying to manipulate the
data and do something with it so what
can I do well for row in rows what do I
want to do let me go ahead and just
print out that's so-and-so registered so
so-and-so registered well how do i plug
in so-and-so well there's a few ways to
do this and let's see first of all I
could use my placeholder syntax for
print and then I want to print out the
row but what do I want from that row
what columns are in any row in this
database ID and name and dorm and phone
and sports well it turns out those are
gonna be handed to you as Python
dictionaries or dict structures so I can
just say row quote unquote name here and
all use single quotes just to make more
clear what's going on here and then I
need to make one fix how do I f4 format
string so it looks a little cryptic but
this is just Python stuff now the only
thing that's new is sequel but if we
stipulate that sequel when using this
execute function it's just gonna hand
you a list of rows each of which is a
dictionary so that you can get at this
column or this column ID or name or dorm
this would seem to be Niall a nice
convergence of this week now with the
past couple of weeks so let me go ahead
and save this let me go ahead and view
my console so I have a terminal window
and let me go ahead and run Python of
lecture pi and in just a moment if I
cross my fingers I should hopefully see
who has registered amazing I've seen
who's registered now there's one line of
output that I didn't expect which is
just this one this is the library
incredibly helpful it's showing me every
command that I sent to the database but
you'll see that so-and-so has registered
so this is kind of interesting it's kind
of a stupid program right because most
Proctor's aren't going to be like
hacking frosh IMS by using a terminal
window and running Python scripts
they're probably going to want to do
this via a web page and actually see who
is registered but if we have the ability
in Python code to do this like iteration
what could I do instead and instead of
just printing to the screen what could I
print out per last week and per the past
problem set I could print out HTML right
like each of the students who register
kind of feels like an opportunity for
like an unordered list or an ordered
list or a table or whatever you can now
generate HTML so let me do this let me
actually go into an example of made in
advance what if I went ahead and opened
up layouts at HTML here is a simple
layout for a web application using flask
for those unfamiliar this is mostly HTML
plus the technology called Jinja what
is a web-based technology for generating
websites dynamically the body of this
page is clearly what's of interest and
you know what I bet I could do some
logic right in there so let me go ahead
and do this let me go ahead and create
let's say a new file let's call this
application dot PI I'm gonna go ahead
and just for time sake do a little bit
of copy-paste to save myself some
keystrokes so here's a very simple web
app and this is going to be my to do so
if I go in here to templates let me open
up index.html and let me go ahead into
here so long story short here's where
we're going with this what if I instead
generate an unordered list using code
from last week but I use my for loop
here inside of my web app instead of
actually just with a simple lecture dot
pi file well recall that I could do
something like this I can have a jinjo
loop so I could say something like four
row in rows and then down here I can
whoops preemptively say something like n
4 which is our weird syntax from last
week and then in here I can just do a
list item and then if I want to show who
registered what what do I type here
something in between these curly braces
if each row represents a registrant row
name registered I can just do something
like this so same idea I'm just wrapping
it with a little bit of HTML now let me
go to my application dot PI file because
I'm gonna have to fill in some blanks
and let me see how can I do this well
ultimately I want to return the result
of rendering a template called
index.html for families unfamiliar this
is just a line of code that says go show
that file to the user but I don't want
to just show them the file as is but
let's at least get this set up I'm
worried that it might not work yet
because I need to get the actual data so
how can I get all of the rows from my
registrants well I can do Rose gets DB
execute and I can go ahead and select
star from registrants and store that in
there this file is called frosh IMDB
that I created earlier and everything
else is just flask stuff from last week
nothing else is new the only thing
that's new is this line here this line
here and now this line here where I'm
using sequel
inside of a Python call bypassing it as
an argument to a function called execute
how do I pass the rows to index dot HTML
yeah like rows equals rows is the
convention we've adopted you can call it
anything you want x equals y but this is
a little more straightforward so this is
saying hey database get me all of the
rows from my registrants and then render
the template next at HTML and pass in
these rows and now if I hold my breath
and run flask run no syntax errors if I
go ahead and visit this here in open
dammit the tab I see an internal server
error so teachable moments families
let's go back into the browser window
here and see what happened okay template
syntax error so pretty stupid mistake it
looks like I expected a square bracket
instead of a curly brace that's fixable
let me go into index dot HTML and oh I
didn't finish my thought
so that's some of the frustrations of
programming for those who are seeing
this for the first time let me save that
let me go back to the browser here and
we'll just reload oh my god voila now I
have a web page via which you can see
who has registered but you know what we
can make this more powerful recall that
we've been playing with HTTP for some
time and if this is the URL I'm
accessing recall that we played around
with like reimplemented search
functionality well what if I want to
support search such that I can just
visit Q equals and then search for
people name say Brian and see how many
Brian's are registered
could we add support for something like
this well maybe let me go back into the
IDE into application PI and let me go
ahead and say something like this Q
equals request dot args get Q to see if
anything is actually there and then let
me go ahead and do this select star from
registrants where let me see Q where
what's name equals Q but I need a
placeholder so maybe I should do this
and as soon as I do this I need to what
F for a format string so I could just
create on the fly a sequel command that
plugs in the value of Q between those
curly braces to express the logic of
select all of the registrants whose
names equal Brian or Veron
or whoever's name i typed in let me go
back to the browser here let me go over
and do something like this now question
mark Q equals Brian crossed my fingers
as before Tim it okay and what did I do
wrong here what did I do wrong here this
is subtle and we're seeing it for the
first time it thinks there's a column
called Brian but why would it think that
well what I've effectively done is sent
in this Brian is not a keyword in sequel
and because it's an actual string that
I'm comparing against what I really need
to be doing is this otherwise sequel
Lite is going to think it's like the
name of a column or something I pre
created so we have to fix this
but that's okay I can put the quotes
there but I should probably put the Q
there in quotes let's save this go back
to the browser reload and there we go
now we have functionality for Brian and
so with this basic building block what
have we done well in sequel we have
several commands at our disposal
creating a table which frankly gets
tedious
by typing it out I myself tend to use
and recommend PHP litem and just to
create your table and get it going but
then you can certainly manually with
sequel Lite through your PHP litem in
insert or update or delete or select
information once it's actually in the
database and that's pretty powerful but
once you do that you can now use that
same new syntax that new language sequel
passing it in as an input with a string
to our execute function and now start
pulling any data you want from your
database last week would CSV files if
you wanted to do this you'd have to open
the CSV file use a for loop to iterate
over it look over every column in row
for your data then pass it in and that's
fine that's correct that's not bad but
it's tedious and you're reinventing the
wheel again and again and there's no
filtration built in as there is to
sequel itself so you now have a more
sophisticated tool in your toolkit so to
speak with which to solve that same kind
of problem any questions then on this
technique
alright well let's look at a bigger
database and see how where we can go
with this so if you go on the courses
website you'll see a larger database
that's actually available in multiple
formats equal light which we'll see in a
moment but also Google Spreadsheets
because frankly it's a lot more pleasant
to like look at your rows and columns in
a GUI than it is necessarily with the
file itself so this happens to be a free
and open source sample database like
some guy years ago took his actual
iTunes database all the music he'd ever
bought he wrote a program to like
analyze apples file format in iTunes and
extract all of the data that seemed to
be stored about him I think was the
story and just made it publicly
available as a sample database for
students and teachers to just use to
manipulate data but what's interesting
is that this database demonstrates some
other principles that we really haven't
touched on for instance if I were to
store again and again all of these
students who are registering for frosh
IMS what do you start to see in certain
fields while I was a little lazy and I
didn't bother typing in everyone's dorm
but suppose that hundreds of students
have registered for frosh Iams a lot of
them are gonna be from Matthews some
from Pennybacker some from Canada some
from wealth and bunches of other
buildings on campus it starts to get a
little ridiculous when you see Matthews
Matthews Matthews Matthews Matthews like
a hundred or more times if there's like
sixteen hundred freshmen there's a lot
of kids in Matthews that's a lot of
bytes to store em ATT HW I don't know
it's not matter how it's spelled that's
a lot of bytes to actually store in your
database again and again and again feels
like there should be an opportunity to
factor out the commonalities and what
humans do with databases is once they
recognize that a recurring pattern of
data same darn strings again and again
and again you know what rather than use
m8 now it matters ma t th e WS which is
8 bytes or PE n and why PA ck e R which
is 11 then we have a lot of bytes being
used again and again and again to store
all of these dorms you know what
what's better than 11 bytes or 8 bytes
let's just use an int or let's even use
a small int 2 bytes or 4 bytes to
represent dorms so instead of storing
Matthews let's just store the number 10
and instead of Pennypacker let's just
store the number 11 there by using some
bytes but fewer and therefore saving
bytes in the long run and so what this
database demonstrates is exactly that
principle certainly when it comes to
music where artists have multiple albums
and artists have multiple songs it's
probably a little silly in a musical
database to store the name of the album
again and again and again and again for
all 10 or 12 or 20 tracks or songs on
that particular album so what this
person did was this notice here we have
a whole bunch of sheets or in database
speak these would be tables and notice
that these tables have columns and
notice that these columns are album ID
in the album table album ID in title but
notice what he did very cleverly with
this field artist ID artists or singers
have lots of songs to their name
eventually and so he's assigned each of
them unique value or Apple did in iTunes
underneath the hood so how do I know
what this artist name is how would you
figure this out I mean it's not that
interesting to us humans do know artist
ID number two this is just what's that
yeah we need another table with artist
which is right over here so let me go
ahead and look there so if I want to see
let's see let there be rock artist
number one let's go to the artist table
and turns out ac/dc the band is who
created that now we've added a step here
which maybe it's costing us a little bit
of time but it's gonna save a space in
the long run if I'm not storing long
artists names although ac/dc isn't
terribly long again and again and again
now which is better well it's a trade
off are you more comfortable wasting
space and storing everything together or
do you prefer to save space and just
spend a little more time joining the
data back together but it's gonna be
really annoying if now if I want to make
a website that shows me the names of the
songs that I have in a database and the
artists for them let alone the albums
and more of that the titles of the
tracks and so forth feels like that's
three queries right like select the
album select the artists select the
titles but no with sequel you can
collapse that altogether because notice
in this table here artist there's a
column called artist ID that's numbers
and notice if you kind of picture this
it's like the fingertips here let's
propose metaphorically represent the
artist ID
if I go into album now notice that we
have album ID and title but we also have
artist ID and so if you imagine these
two tables sharing this common this
common column what if we kind of stitch
them together like this lining up one on
the left the other on the right there by
reconstructing all of the information
and duplicating it as needed so that I
get back just the album and the title
and the artist well how can i express
that well let me go ahead into cs50 IDE
where I have a copy of this file let me
close all of my tabs from earlier and go
into this file called lecture dB and in
lecture dot DB in PHP lighted men will
see all of those same tables and I
literally just imported it into sequel
Lite you'll see all these same tables we
can browse album just as before and we
just see a different format for the same
data it's the same data from the Google
spreadsheet which is just more
user-friendly and let me go ahead and do
this I could of course select star from
album where our artist ID equals one to
get back all of a cdc's albums and
indeed here I have two they have for
those about to rock we salute you and
let there be rock they have two but
notice the rows I got back contain only
what information album ID title an
artist ID
I just know as a human that oh these are
a cdc's albums but what if I want to
know well okay I see that artist ID is
one so all right well let me open like
another tab here and now let me select
star from artists where artist ID equals
one and so if I want to learn something
about that artist let me go ahead and
zoom out click go and okay now I get
ac/dc well this is great now I have two
results two sets of rows this is stupid
like now I'm just creating work for
myself by having to return values I
could call DB execute Weiss but there's
a better way it turns out sequel allows
you to join tables just using sequel
itself so I'm gonna go ahead and do this
I'm gonna go ahead and select star from
album but also from artist where album
artist ID
and let me scroll to the right equals
artist dot artist ID so notice I'm
saying select everything from two tables
but only do so where the album tables
artist ID column has the same value as
the artist tables artist ID column
that's kind of the stitching
metaphorically if my fingers together
looking for that common column if I go
ahead and click go wow look at what I've
just constructed it's a lot of
information but I have album ID and
title I have artist ID still but I have
the name of that artist all together so
if you now let your mind wander back to
the PHP the Python code I could now get
a whole bunch of rows containing
everything I care about all at once I
don't need to select queries I can join
these tables in this way and I use join
very deliberately it turns out that
there's another way to express the same
thing instead of using that comma syntax
I did you might see as well this select
star from artists join album on artists
dot artist ID equals let me scroll over
album dot artist ID this is gonna have
the exact same effect but you might just
find that it reads a little more
intuitively to you select everything
from the result of joining these two
tables how do you want to join them well
join them on this equaling that just
another way of expressing the same idea
and if I click go I get back the same
information so ultimately with joins do
we have the ability to reassemble data
so on the one hand it's just good
practice to normalize your database
identify columns that have lots and lots
and lots of redundancy and only store
that information once for instance cs50
finance if you're supporting many
different users every time Malin or
Brian or Veronica buys the stock feels
that could be a little silly to store
Malin or Brian or Veronica along with
Netflix the symbol and the number of
shares one of us bought because male and
male and male and male ins can appear
all throughout the database and what if
I change my username or my name or
someone gets married and therefore it
changes like why do you create that
messiness for yourself instead give
Brian and Veronica and me and everyone
else a unique ID and when they buy
something just store their you
or ID or customer ID or however you want
to think about it just like with album
ID and artist ID and so normalizing a
database is all about finding those
commonalities and moving the data into
its own table and if you care about
rejoining it just use sequel to
reconstruct that view of the data so to
speak so what else can we do here as
well it turns out that there is in
sequel not just primary Keys but there's
unique constraints in some databases
where you can specify this isn't my
primary key but I want it to be unique
you can act specify that something
should be indexed so it turns out that
if you just know there's a field in your
database that you want to be able to
search on very efficiently you can index
it in advance and you'll see you're
being able to do this if you like for
final projects or even for the next
problem set if you'd like but what this
enables are queries like this if I want
to go ahead and search for for instance
let's say what would be a good example
Rock I'm interested in rock so if I want
to go into my sequel tab here I could
say something like this select star from
album where name not equals but where
name is like and then I'm gonna say rock
but if I want any number of characters
could to come before that word I can use
a percent sign and if any number of
characters after I can use a percent
sign these are like wildcards in most
languages you would use star in sequel
you use percent signs but it means the
same thing and if I go ahead and say go
now I get back up I get got wrong
lecture album Oh title I think is what I
wanted let me try that again sorry where
title like rock let me go ahead and
click go and voila here are all of the
albums in the database that have the
word rock in them now as an aside this
table has a lot of more albums in it and
it frankly it's small enough though it
has hundreds of rows maybe a few
thousand rows none of us humans are
really going to notice how slowly near
searches but if you start having
thousands of rows tens of thousands of
rows millions of rows not having an
index means that searching for something
like rock is going to start at the top
and search every darn field all the way
to the bottom Big O of n if you instead
tell the database I know I'm going to be
searching on this column a lot please
Index it for me here comes the secret
sauce sequel by
Oracle Microsoft's access and so forth
they will using their own intellectual
property build up some fancy data
structures trees or hash tables or
whatever in-memory store the data for
you in trance invisibly in that format
so that when you do ask for a question
like show me all the albums like rock
they can answer you in a much faster
time than linear and that too is what
you get with sequel that you don't get
with CSVs CSVs are by nature only linear
so we can do better but you the
programmer have to help the database and
actually give it those hints not just
the types but also hints like this and
as an aside there's also the notion of
foreign keys where if you really want to
lock things down you can specify that if
you ever see an album ID in another
table it if it's a primary key in the
album table by definition in the other
table it's gonna be called a foreign key
because it doesn't really belong there
but it's referencing a column elsewhere
so there's a lot more technology and
vocabulary and you're welcome to dive in
deeper and odds are many of you will for
final projects by nature of wanting
certain features among them even the
ones we've seen like auto incrementing
and not know as an aside to sequel even
has functions and for data scientists
and statisticians it's super useful to
be able to just do math and summaries of
data right within sequel without ever
writing Python code or are anything else
built into sequel white and other light
and other databases or functions like
this for average counting things getting
the min/max sum and so forth all of that
you get for free with a lot of databases
all it takes in the context of Python is
a line like this but-but-but-but but
there are some problems and let's end by
taking a look at two fundamental
problems and threats that are too often
underappreciated and in fact we have to
fix a very serious vulnerability that I
introduced into my very own code earlier
but first the so called race condition
in survey you are rather let's see
suppose that we think back at the very
start of the semester most of you signed
up for a github account for the very
first time and you went to github.com
slash sign up for those unfamiliar
github as a website where you can save
and store a programming code that you've
written and want to collaborate with
others on and you chose a username and
let me go ahead and try choosing a
username like say J Harvard for John
Harvard notice that the website
immediately said the username is
all right that's useful and you can
probably guess how this is done maybe a
little JavaScript using Ajax talking to
the server getting the response changing
the HTML or the CSS or whatever it might
take some time to wire all that together
but that's probably what's going on so
let me try like a really long random
username that is not taken
hey it's available but probably is not a
good thing and I'm streaming this on the
internet because if I wait long enough I
bet someone could for a plateful of
reasons just sign up for this let alone
anyone in this room but you've just told
me it's available
okay so good I'm really excited I've got
my username let me go ahead and type in
my email address mail and at Harvard ID
you my password one two three four five
take a few moments there verify my
account and so forth and I click Submit
suppose that I'm told momentarily sorry
that usernames been taken could that
happen yeah I mean if any of you were
trying to mess with me like right now
you would have signed up for that
username and beating me to the punch so
that when I hit join I get an error
that's the definition of a race
condition where two people or two users
or two computers or two threads if we
really roll back to our discussion of
threads in scratch are trying to do the
same thing at roughly the same time and
if those two things threads or humans
check the state of a variable which is
the fancy way of saying is the username
available they both get back answers but
then some number of split seconds later
then they make a decision based on that
information there is a window of time
either split seconds or even seconds or
minutes where the state of that variable
could have course change so if you two
literally right now on your laptop type
that very long username all of us would
probably be told like green light it's
available but only one of us is actually
going to get it and that's because of a
race conditions literally all of us can
might be racing to sign up for that
value and it's when state can change in
between things happening this is a bad
thing because it makes your data
vulnerable to changes by someone you
don't necessarily intend or if the
database isn't smart you might be able
to do especially bad things ATMs or a
canonical example of this if you had a
malicious adversary trying to log in to
like two bank accounts at once or two
physical machines at once now there were
two cards there were two counts and two
laptops you could imagine both of them
trying to deduct like a
under dollars from the same account
instantly because imagine a poorly
implemented Bank website it checks they
count Stalin's account balance of the
user logged in do you have $100 if the
answer is yes
maybe both websites are gonna say yes
you may deduct $100 you hit it enter in
wallah you deduct $100 the user gets it
somehow because it's transferred to some
other accounts but the bank thinks it
only did that once the ducks a hundred
but you've just walked away with 200
because you got a made a decision based
on the same answer in two different
threads or two different programs or two
different computers so long story short
this can happen even in the real world
an example I was taught by my advisor
years ago was this suppose you and your
roommates of a little dorm fridge and
you're in a habit of course of drinking
a lot of of milk and so the the fridge
has run out of milk and you come home
the first roommate after classes and
you're realizing oh I really need a
drink of milk and so you check the
fridge there's nothing there so you
close the fridge and you walk into the
square go to CVS and get in line in to
buy some milk meanwhile your other your
roommate comes home also they really
need a drink of milk and so they check
the state of the variable no milk close
the fridge and then walk to like Tommy's
convenience or some other place nearby
and get in line for some milk you of
course then both get home eventually and
what happens now dammit now you have
twice as much milk and you know if one
milk goes bad quickly so now this is a
problem a very bad problem you have
twice as much milk as you could possibly
drink but what's the origin of that
problem fundamentally you're out of
something but you need it but why did I
end up with two there's no flag right
there's no indication there's no sharing
of State you both inspected the value of
the variable made a decision
independently on it but the state of
that variable changed on one of you
because when one of you came home the
later person damn liked the milk has
already been refilled so how do you
solve this in the real world how could
you avoid this problem you just one
never do errands for your roommate Mag
yes a shopping list right gone for a
milk Arrested Development always leave a
note right you could blot you could
convey that information you could more
dramatically lock the refrigerator right
padlock the thing and so your roommate
can't inspect the state of the
refrigerator while you are gone
therefore not making us vulnerable to
this and I use the word lock
deliberately because in databases that's
how they solve this there is a feature
and database is called locks or fancier
versions of this are called transactions
whereby you can guarantee something
called a de Missa tee where Adam Missa
tee means you can do multiple things
back to back to back without getting
interrupted so in the case of a bank it
is possible with sequel using slightly
fancier syntax that we won't dive into
today to solve this problem by saying
you know what begin the following
transaction check the state of the bank
accounts deduct this amount of money and
now commit the results and while I'm
doing that lock everyone else out don't
let any other customer or any other user
do exactly that information that touches
the same data until I am done long story
short you pay a price perhaps you're
literally preventing your roommate from
accessing the fridge and that's annoying
or you're preventing other customers
from doing transactions so hopefully the
computer is fast at this and you're fast
at shopping but you've at least ensured
that you have atomicity no operation can
get inserted into your sequence of
operations as by your roommate or some
other computer or threat so that's a
problem with databases that we're only
going to skirt over and github might
solve this how well by just not caring
potentially I don't know what's gonna
happen if multiple of us try I'm
guessing they will just give n minus one
of us an error message saying sorry that
usernames no longer available think
about this if you've ever bought airline
tickets this is a solved problem in that
industry it would be really annoying if
you just spent like an hour of stressful
price hunting for a good airline ticket
you start checking out after adding it
to your shopping cart in five minutes
later after your name and email address
and credit card number the tickets gone
so what do airlines do they often give
you like a five-minute window and some
of the fancier web sites show you the
clock saying we guarantee this for the
next five minutes hotels might do this
to where they lock the refrigerator for
you by somehow altering the database to
say mmm no one else can buy this ticket
or this room for the next five minutes
much like the note or the padlock so
those kinds of things are all around us
but let's look one final example that's
the worst threat of all is this
previously I allowed myself to search by
name so Q equals Brian or Q equals David
or
or the light and what did I do with that
information well if we go back into the
IDE and actually look at that file in
application PI
I simply formatted it using an F string
inside of this sequel string but what if
my users were a little bit malicious and
suppose that someone doesn't want to
just search for Brian but you know what
suppose they do something like my query
is delete from registrants we're sorry
Brian name equals Brian something like
this now this is not valid at the moment
because this string while I'm certainly
allowed to type it in is gonna get
plugged into my code but in the wrong
place logically like I'm gonna look for
someone's name called delete from
registrants where name equals burnt
which is just nonsensical it will return
zero results but what if I do something
like this where I say Brian or delete
from registrants where I kind of
finished the thought that the programmer
had and then start my own new thought or
another way of doing this is to use
special syntax semicolon something like
this long story short I could contrive a
human malicious input that finishes the
programmers thought and returns zero
rows but by the way also sneaks one
additional rogue query into the database
this is what's known as a sequel
injection attack and if you naively and
very very very embattled like I did
don't ever do this you will be
vulnerable to exactly this attack
because you are blindly plugging in the
users input to a string that you are
then passing to a database this is a
fundamental flaw in lots of applications
lots of languages where you have to
distrust your users it doesn't matter if
it's for just students on campus or it's
just for you and your friends never ever
ever trust users input because either
someone's gonna miss type something and
something's gonna go awry or you're
gonna have like a bad apple trying to
hack into your website your application
by trying these kinds of commands and
you have to do always write code
defensively so how to do this there's a
bunch of ways but it turns out that
what's dangerous about something like I
just typed in is that it's the semicolon
for instance and it's the quote marks
over
elsewhere so the safest thing to do is
no matter what the user types in escape
things you can use special syntax we saw
this in see generally putting a
backslash in front of something means
don't have let it have its default
behavior instead treat it specially so
you could use special code in Python
that just says remove any bad characters
or replace things frankly you've
probably been to a web site where you've
been told sorry you can't use that
character in your password or sorry you
can't use that in your username that's
just dumb like that is the lazy approach
to this there is no reason to prevent
users from typing any characters into
their keyboard for their password and
maybe even their username that's kind of
a lazy way of defending against this by
saying I don't trust any percent signs
any semicolons any - is any apostrophes
rather just escape things but it's silly
for all of us in this room to write our
own code for scaping users input or
scrubbing it as it's called or
sanitizing it as it's called same things
why don't we just use a library now
there's many Annelle libraries out there
the one that we're using at the moment
is cs50 s and the execute function does
this for us instead of using f strings
which you should not use like this you
should instead do this if you want to
plug in a placeholder value to a sequel
query you literally use a standard
convention that we have adopted to where
you just put in a variables name but
with a colon in front of it and it can
be anything it can be Q it can be X it
doesn't matter but you want to just plug
in some value there so I'm going to call
it name by convention then you close
your quote and finish your thought and
then you go ahead and pass in the actual
value name equals Q and now you have
constructed dynamically a sequel string
with a placeholder that is not pythons
own curly brace placeholder this is a
special sequel convention where you say
plug in value here what value will plug
in this names value Q whatever the human
is typed in and what our execute
function will do for you is all of the
fancy back slashing and all of the
escaping and will protect you from the
users data and this is how truly simple
it is doesn't have to be cs50 library
this is ever so common in all languages
but too few people know about it and use
it and so half the time you read about
some database getting hacked or your
data getting stolen it is because of a
stupid oversight
like that so just use libraries and
escape users input we can see this now
more concretely all the undergrads in
the room have surely logged into other
Yale's website or Harvard's website
which looks a little something like this
here you're prompted for your login name
and your password or your Harvard key or
the like well how does this take effect
in real terms if I were to type in my
email address
but then weird syntax like this let's
look at an example quote or quote
unquote one equals quote one notice it's
not balanced like it's kind of missing a
quote over here missing a quote over
here because the presumption is that
maybe Harvard is vulnerable to this I
don't think they are but suppose that
the code running Harvard key and
Harvard's login page looks a little
something like this this is bad this is
dangerous because they're just using F
strings or format strings which are just
going to blindly plug anything in there
but if you instead use and so if you let
the human type in something cryptic like
that notice what has happened logically
where username equals me at example
email provider comm and password equals
quote unquote
so nothing or one equals one and y 1
equals one will notice if I go back
notice that there's a quote here and a
quote here and the reason that I didn't
finish my second quote here or my second
quote here is because I'm assuming is a
bad guy like I think Harvard is just
gonna blindly plug my input into a
single quotes of their own therefore I
can finish their thought nonsensically
but notice logically what happens select
all users from the database where the
username is me at example email provider
comm and the password is nothing or one
equals one well when does one equal one
like always so this will always return
users from the database and presumably
therefore let me log in as one of those
users so incredibly simple to defend
against this just use placeholder syntax
and distrust and sanitize users input
the syntax in sequel and the cs50
library is quite simply with that colon
but in other libraries it might be quite
the same so now you are all families and
students alike inaugurate it into the
small class of folks in the world to
understand particularly geeky humor
you might notice this meme that's gone
around the internet for many years now
where someone either maliciously or
humorously decided to paint
over there license plate let's enhance
why would someone do this scanners yeah
like toll booths are kind of going away
at least in the US and they instead have
like cameras or readers that are
scanning the front of your car and
trying to optically a Cara do OCR
optical character recognition on your
license plate and the presumption here
is maybe in some municipality there's
some badly written code where they just
blindly plug your license plate into
their code and hopefully you finished
the thought we're zu zero six six six
whatever that is is part of the license
plate but semicolon drop database table
dot dot on we can even look at that cuz
drop is pretty extreme it literally
deletes a database itself but this is a
nice way of getting off the hook from a
12 price and most canonical perhaps xkcd
is a very popular cartoon strip it's
particularly geek oriented and you'll
perhaps understand this joke now as well
among CS circles
you can send hear the laughter making
its way through so for here on out if
you take nothing else away remember
little Bobbie tables with P set our
final will you actually implement cs50
finance and coalesce all these ideas
thank you so much to all of our families
for joining and we will see you next
time